ambiance plus familiale à
palavas-les-flots touristes et régionaux
se retrouvent en ce long week-end pour
goûter aux joies de la plage reportage
de laura 14 ski et série le paquet férié
ou pas en général et journée à palavas
ça se passe là ou là comme tous les
jours rendez vous avec son petit coin de
plage mais aujourd'hui c'était encore
plus difficile de se faire une place au
soleil
forcément 15 août oblige on rencontre
plein de petits nouveaux venus jouer les
vacanciers juste pour trois jours au
programme donc ça va être pour les
plages
vu que c'est juste ce week-end si est
génial et il faut donc se coller aux
habitués encore là c'est le début ou la
fin des vacances là on est toujours en
vacances ça fait vingt ans que ça dure
mais palavas les flots ses cinquante
mille personnes l'été deux fois plus le
week-end du 15 août en raison de
l'afflux de tous les gens de la région
tous ceux qui ont la chance d'habiter à
13h au rayon de 1h ou 2h autour de la
mer auprès de la mer viennent le matin
repartent le soir et il en profite et
quand il ya un vendredi 15 août comme
aujourd'hui
le samedi le dimanche donc qui viennent
la journée et parfois ils passent la
nuit mais comme tout est déjà loué la
semaine par des résidents en général ils
viennent en surnombre chez des amis et
quand on a pas d'hébergement gratuit
reste par exemple le camping les au
point fort de la saison toutes affichent
complet
à tout hasard on tente quand même
catherine quand vous avez les on a
appris que c'était le week-end du 15
août pour pouvoir repartir pour avoir
trois jours de congé voilà mais c'est un
peu la galère pour trouver visiblement
coup de chance une place vient de se
libérer elles vont donc pouvoir elle
aussi rejoindre la plage et dès ce soir
pour le feu d'artifice du 15 août